good
morning call a fiscal committee meeting
to order for November 9th
2023 and welcome Senator Susi filling in
for Senator Rosenwald and representative
Heath filling in for representative
Lehman
um first item on the agenda is
acceptance of the minutes of October
19th so move
second a motion by Senator gray second
by Senator Bradley to adopt the minutes
from October 19th further discussion
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say I
I motion is adopted we welcome Senator
him should I say 10 instead of nine yes
he was at the door oh you can say nine
and then and okay she didn't vote
but all right there is no old business
under tab two we have a consent calendar
from tab three through tab
six is there any member that wishes any
consent I'll move the uh consent second
motion by Senator Bradley second by
Senator gray to adopt the consent
calendar tabs 3 through six
any further discussion seeing none are
you ready for the question all in favor
say I I oppose no consent calendar is
adopted moving on to the regular
seven first item is 23
339 Department of Health and Human
Services
transferring $15 million and so on
between various class lines any any
members Senator dallesandro moves to
approve the item second seconded by
Senator gray is there any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is
adopted moving on to Tab
item 23
322 Office of the governor see
we oh he
left his budget oh his budget man's here
okay uh any questions on on the item 23
322 by members of the
committee move the item all right seeing
none motion to approve the
item by Senator Dallas Andro seconded by
senator gray is there any further
discussion seeing none you're ready for
the question all in favor of adopting
23322 say I I oppose no that item is
adopted moving on to tab
nine an item from fishing game
23323 for water test for the fish
hatcheries any questions from committee
members
seeing
none Senator dallesandro moves the
item seconded by Bradley seconded by
Senator Bradley is there any further
discussion on the
item seeing none all in favor say I I
oppose
23325 from New Hampshire fishing game
again any questions on the
item Senator gray uh we would like to
get an update on the
progress
question Senator uh gray is Rec for a
question um since uh we have in hb2
clarification there was some controversy
between the department and the senate
about uh what was going to be done
wanted to get to an update since we
asking for
25,000 um Scott Mason executive director
New Hampshire fishing game um yes
Senator uh this what we're asking for is
$25,000 which will be the contractual
amount for the supplier for the software
um we have had a couple of minor
setbacks um we have been working with a
company called S3 and they have been
purchased by a company called pay it and
that did slow down the the process in
between the the renewal contract and the
new contract um the I think the good I
think this is actually a good thing for
us um S3 was a company that only dealt
with fishing game issues licensing
um hunting lottery stuff like that um
pay is a bigger company that does other
types of work including automobile
registration so I think that they
actually bring some new skills to the
table for us and I think it'll actually
be very helpful on this particular item
um the other issue that has taken place
um the uh employee that was in charge of
our licensing and registration
um um section uh has has retired and we
have have just recently replaced her
with a new employee and um we believe
things will be moving a little quicker
now that we have uh that change over in
place um I think the big issue that
still lays ahead of us is when we get
into uh fulfillment uh we will probably
need to hire an additional employee um
one of the issues with online
registration versus our um our historic
registration system that relied upon
agents the agents supplied the labor to
fulfill you know to hand over the
registration um here fishing game will
be be in that process obviously on
online these folks won't be standing in
the office we'll be having to mail that
out so we are anticipating the need for
um an additional employee when we get
there at this time we do believe that we
will be on target for September 1st 19
I'm sorry 2025
deadline further question uh and that
will include both uh renewals and new
registrations yes
sir thank you further questions from
committee
members want attain a motion to dispose
and did he say September
25 yes
I believe that's that's the deadline in
right
okay that's that's a year off yes
sir yeah that's like almost two years
ago
right okay if we can't move any faster
than that we're in
trouble we've been talking about this
like forever and and now we we we find
out person who was there is gone we have
to replace that person we may need
another person and uh the uh efficiency
and Effectiveness that we were looking
for did you put your mic down sure sure
it it these timelines don't make any
sense to me is is what I'm saying here
we we we've talked about this and now
we're talking about two years and uh our
our goal was to expedite
this I thought anyway that's that seemed
to be the the conversation that was
around this table the last time we met
let's get it done right now uh now it's
off until 25 um as I remember the
conversation at the finance committee
meeting um that uh uh by September of
2025 uh the old commitment was from the
Department was to only have one and I
don't remember whe it was renewals
online by by then uh and that date was
in their opinion
not firm okay so right now it is an
improvement if we have a firm date for
both the new registrations and renewals
and certainly Senator I would encourage
all of us uh to encourage them to uh to
improve on that date uh because the
Snowmobile Association and a few others
uh are very very very vocal on this and
uh so but if if they can come back with
something you know a request that
enables them to cut a year off of this
or whatever I'm sure that uh both you
and I will entertain and do what we can
right well I enthusiastically support
Expediting the situation I think just it
just makes a lot of
sense and if I may I didn't know if U Mr
Mason wanted to add anything to what I
said um no I would just remind the
committee um part of the issues facing
the department um we had other
requirements that predated the online
registration requirement and we have
been working diligently on those and
what we have done basically is put them
in line
um we are this is the first year that
we're offering online deer registration
that has been going very well
um we shut down online deer registration
uh twice during the season so that we
can collect biological samples of deer
coming into registration stations today
happens to be one of those days but in
the early part of the Season we were
running about a 61% online registration
participation of our Hunters um so I
would dare say that that that has been a
fairly successful program um the next in
line is to uh change our online
licensing program so that if you have a
suspended license anywhere in the United
States you will not be able to buy a
license in New Hampshire um which
Believe It or Not uh for most folks the
inability to buy a license is a bigger
um
um penalty than actually a cash penalty
that they also receive when they when
they do a violation so those are the
things that we've been working on the
other the third issue that we're
currently working on and will continue
to work on is we're having to update our
a lot of our database systems that are
no longer supported by the software
company so we are in the process of
updating 12 of those so that's why we
needed some extra time all the different
projects that we're doing on on the
computer front in the
department further questions from
committee
members did we already have a motion on
this yes we did second all right a
motion we don't have a second on the
motion
second from Senator
Bradley any any further discussion
seeing none ready for the question all
in favor of adopting say I I oppose
no thank you director that is adopted
thank you and we move next to a late
item f
23340 um sorry rep chairman wer under
tab 11 is 23326 it's a request by the
Department of Treasury to release the
unique sorry in I see the treasurer is
here all right under tab 11 23326 will
be the next item on the agenda a request
to release the audit from the
is okay motion by Senator dallesandro
second by Senator Susi to adopt the
report any further discussion among the
committee members seeing none all in
favor say I I oppose no
that report is adopted Now we move on to
23340 Department of HHS dealing with the
uh building of transferring money from
Opera from to the construction of the
new Youth Development
Center are there any questions on
this from the
blazel bir I've only known you for 20
years I'm sorry I know Senator
birel thank you um and thank you for
taking my question
um as you know um we're working on the
security aspect of um the Youth
Development
Center um in
Hamstead and
I I have to say I have some concerns um
so so we authorized 21
million um in um the house bill for the
building of the um Youth Development
Center in Hamstead um now we need it
looks like we're you're going to need an
additional is it 9,000 six or uh million
six and a half million six million
roughly yes okay um for what
purpose sure thank you than for the
question Lori Weaver commissioner HHS
for the record um so I let me this a
great question why are we here so back
with HB 49 um 21 million and with that
legislation came specific elements that
needed to be involved in that design for
a safe environment and a therapeutic
environment so at the time that we did
the 21 million as we do with a lot of
our projects with DPW we don't have uh
an architect on board we do our best
guesstimate at projection of cost at
that time so given all that we had that
was the uh estimate that we're at was at
21 million since then we hired an
architect when we sat down with our
teams of DPW HHS and the architect we
realized that what was in scope and spec
was going to cost more than 21 million
so what the team did um
for at least three or four weeks was to
try to make it work can we make these
numbers work can we look at uh we have
budgeted and those specs and it just
wasn't working so then we began to cut
um and when you cut you cut space so we
did our Cuts as much as we could without
sacrificing safety and those components
so at the end of the day I think the
original with the architect we were
almost looking at Double the square
footage we got that down to 32,000
Square ft um as opposed to the I think
it was the 25,000 um grow square feet so
there was a lot of cuts a lot of but at
the same time not sacrificing the safety
um component of it so um we don't come
to ask with this lightly this is
obviously a serious ask we know what was
budgeted for it but at the same time I
can't tell you in good conscious that I
can build a facility that's safe and
meets those requirements with the 21
million so we looked within our budget
of where did we have that we wouldn't be
spending general fund dollars to be able
to reallocate and working with gopher um
and d and and Nathan's team um and
that's where that money is so our goal
is to be able to stay within that um
there's contingencies built into that as
well because we know by the time we
start construction we'll be a little bit
of time out from now and if you've ever
done any construction right now at your
house or anything you know that there
it's hard and prices and supply chain
and all of that um are challenges so
that's why we're
at
followup thank you for that commissioner
the other concern I have is seeing that
the issues that we've had at Hamad
Hospital currently and I know the Youth
Development Center is going to be much
more is probably going to be much more
secure but um based on what I'm reading
here the population has
changed at the youth detention center
now a third are wav to adult status and
we'll be at the facility until their age
of their 18th birthday um a third have
been committed to serve their sentences
at the facility but then a fourth have
gang affiliations all of whom be
separated by Sight and Sound how can you
guarantee the town of
Hamstead that we're not going to have
juveniles absconding I'm nervous as it
is and now we have gang affiliations
coming into Hamstead I'm nervous about
what's going to happen and the security
aspect of the Youth Development Center
in
Hamstead sure I so we have gang
affiliated youth now more than we've had
in the past but we don't always have
gang affiliated youth but there is a
rise in gain activity in our bigger
cities for sure um one of the things
that we're looking at is how do we um as
a state work to make sure we provide
resources and try to keep kids out of
the system and that's when we think
about our Juvenile Justice
transformation efforts we've reduced
it's 50% of kids that used to be going
into the system we've now reduced that
by 50% so what we're looking at for an
eye towards the future is we have 18
beds can't go above 18 beds we're going
to stick with those 18 beds and then
make sure that kids that don't need to
enter that system aren't but they're
still getting the care that they need
otherwise so that's what we're going to
be and have been focusing on and will
continue to focus on so that the youth
that are there or the youth that are
absolutely required to be there but also
don't languish there I think that's
another piece of this when we have youth
that are committed it's hard if that's
going to be their home for the next
three years that's that's a really hard
place to be so we're working to make
sure that um we don't have kids
languishing there that they have
opportunity to get Services otherwise
and I would tell you the facility at in
Manchester is very secure and I my
expectation is with the money that we
have to do this build that this facility
has to be just as secure as
you representative Edwards for a
question uh uh thank you Mr chair uh
thank you commissioner for taking my
questions I I I think I have like three
little ones um the because we're in a
design phase of the physical facility
we've I I understand that uh we have to
plan on 18 but it's still the case that
operationally we're anticipating about
12 is that is that does that still hold
up I think it's really hard to to
project out what we're going to have in
in three years I know that we had a an
average of 12 when we the time the
legislation passed that's what we were
looking at our census has been higher
than that since the spring it's averaged
around
19 huh okay um followup follow up
um when I when I think we started
talking about the
21.6 million for the facility U all of
the estimates that we use that you
pointed out came internally from the
department and and as opposed to
Architects um the the initial plan uh
was uh to to build a standalone facility
and since uh then I think a lot more
time has been spent on trying to figure
out how to really integrate the services
and um and and um and the shared
services between the two facilities
it's some amount of this additional
dollar cost it seems to me needs to be
associated with making sure that we've
integrated the security systems we've
integrated the physical facility uh and
those I don't believe were included in
the original
21.6 estimate am I mistaken when you say
integrate the the security can you be
more
specific it it Okay so we've we've been
taking a look at the security at
Hamstead now we're bringing in a new
building uh with with additional kids it
seems to me like we have to make sure
that there is a
comprehensive uh security system uh to
ensure uh the public safety around the
building uh and that um and that we have
the hamstad security we have the YDC
security but we really need a
campus-wide security program and that
that's that's that to me seems bigger
than what what we had anticipated
mistaken well I think it would be fair
to say that we may not have anticipated
how big the need would have been at that
time so I think there's an opportunity
here to look at the campus as a whole to
your point Senator bdel about the the
security and the component of it how do
we maximize that resource for that
particular
campus okay
so so in addition to the inflation and
the additional square footage um there
there are other aspects to this request
that are going to make sure that these
two buildings are represent sort of an
integrated campus environment I is is
hear yeah I I in terms of the specifics
I think of this money I think it's bound
to if correct me if I'm wrong I the
bounds of what this money for is for the
YDC bill that doesn't mean that we can't
have an impact on the campus but I can't
take this money here and spend it on
something for the hospital but if I'm
talking about U safety on a campus and
that there's a piece of that that I'll
probably have to consider a financial
end from the Hamstead side as well not
just the YDC side okay that that that's
a good answer um thank
you
um thank you very much so in the budget
um somehow an amendment did not get
included in the final version of the
budget that dealt with hamad's payment
in Le of taxes I'm assuming that the um
payment has been made yes okay and will
be on an ongoing basis yes I believe we
have legislation to be make sure that it
does get included for this session Y and
there's if I can follow follow up um can
you address some of the ongoing security
issues um how maybe it's changed at the
hospital before we get to YDC I mean I
hear some people think it's approving
other people say no it isn't but I'd
like to hear what you have to say sure
so I think this the hospital that the
state purchased had a history of having
uh clientele that were probably a little
bit different than what we have now that
said since Co we know that mental health
has been a significant issue for many of
our youth many of our citizens in the
state and we've seen an increase in
Acuity part of the goal in purchasing
the hospital is that we would be able to
serve all of those folks that we
wouldn't be saying you know you but not
you it would be that we'd be able to
provide that and at the same time we we
took over the hospital we had a
transition vendor come in at the time we
we had said we were always going to RFP
that service but for the startup we
would do that and I think we've had a
rocky startup I mean I I don't think you
know I'm not going to sugarco quote that
we've been clear we've been clear with
the town we've met with the town um I
think when you look at the data from uh
we had a rough summer but you look after
the summer September October we started
to level out a little bit part of that
leveling out is our intentional we have
leadership there that's uh constantly
working with the vendor to say adjust
here adjust there this isn't working
push and pull all of that and I and I
think it's had an impact it's going to
be um a constant effort to make sure
that the the children are safe and that
the facility is um not dis in the town
and not an over Demand on the services
in the town and we're trying to strike
that balance constantly I'm I'm
confident we can get there it's going to
take us a minute though um so I would
like to you know we have an RFP that's
going out we're in November Yep this
month uh for uh the service for the
clinical Psychiatry at the at the Hamad
hospital and we're hoping to award a new
Vendor by the end of this fiscal year um
and and hope to see continued in Pro
progress so that by the time we get to a
YDC build we're not we're not in this
spot right now but we're in it and I I I
acknowledge that okay thank you senator
blazedale for a question Senator bird
cell I'm gonna start changing my name
representative Mr chair I'll just call
you
Regina okay
um I I had talked to Dr hanen prior um
one one thing I forgot to ask you was um
based on the footprint we requested as
the commission we had requested to take
a look at the footprint uh the design
footprint that was going to be on the
campus um I'd like to see if we can get
uh for our next commission meeting on
the 20th if we can get a copy of a
portrayal of what the what the initial
footprint would have been and a
footprint of the additional space to see
what what difference the commission can
take a look at what difference it it
would make sure we can do that thank
you um if I may uh procedurally and you
know preaching to the choir uh there's
two things that Mr Kane knows that I I
dislike and that's uh the word
retroactive uh but also late okay and
certainly I didn't get a copy of this
late item until yesterday at the meeting
with Mr Kaine it is such an important
issue um that you know bringing it to us
uh within 24 hours of you know when
we're going to to hear it uh certainly
is generating a lot of these questions
which could have been taken care of
ahead of time uh not that you have to
comment but just for future uh you know
knowledge that uh you know taking a late
item on a
very a topic that is very near and dear
to a lot of us uh is not a good idea may
I may I comment absolutely I don't like
the word late either um I agree with you
I think I if we had the choice to bring
this and wait till December we would
have but we're running out of time given
that the money we're using is upper
money for this project as you all know
there's timelines and constrictions and
we're still trying to work with the
architect so the longer we wait the
longer we put off the design and the
more we put the project at risk so we
did not take the request to ask lightly
um and we knew that it was a significant
topic it would generate project uh
questions which is why I'm sitting here
right now thank
you represent of Earth for a question no
my question that took care of it no
any
yes wner for a question thank
you when we were working on the Hamstead
budget during the February and March
last
year um something that came up a lot was
is that the Staffing there was an issue
and um they had a lot of vacancies has
that
improved at Hamstead Hospital yes um
yeah I would say that it's in a better
spot than it was before but it there's
attrition is um steady at many of our
247 facilities it's hard to um attract
and keep staff in those
positions further question further
question so what sort of vacancy rate do
you think Hamstead hospital has at this
point I don't have that off the top of
my
head it well yeah it varies by position
but do we have an aggregate we can get
that to you I don't have it okay at my
fingertips and one further question F
the question so the increase of um
square footage that um this item
addresses will hopefully address um
there is no anticipation here that you
will go over 18 children at that site is
that correct
you um Senor birel further just Dr Han
correct me if I'm wrong because I just
did the interm report so the numbers are
kind of in my head but when we started
the commission and like I said Dr hen
correct me if I'm wrong um the at least
at Hamstead hospital I think the
management was at 100%
the
um and I think the youth counselors is
that what they're YC's are were at for
50 to
60% are we talking Hamstead or or
YDC I think we're talking Hamstead okay
because they're at y the YC's are at YDC
I I think um okay the state has uh we
have our leadership positions which are
um full except for our CEO which are in
the process of of getting a new CEO for
the State Side uh they have nurses and
clinicians and Direct Care staff so
there's different numbers for each of
those
categories I think the the
[Music]
um the management I know was 100% And I
think the lower Echelon they were
looking at um anywhere from 50 to 60%
vacancy rate we can get it to you I I I
don't want to best guest but we can get
you representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair it it took me a while to think
about it um um but uh I I I think I'm a
little concerned that um our census is
has has been holding in around the 19
level when all the all the trends
indicated that 12 would be a good uh
estimate for uh future operational
capacity and so I I would appreciate it
if uh offline or back to the fiscal
committee or over to oversight if we
could get an update on the numbers uh
that we're looking at for the census
because uh we we I think we were
anticipating that in the future budgets
when the YDC came in it would be built
around uh a census of 12 and so I'm
starting to hear that maybe uh that was
not a good um planning estimate on our
part so so if we could just if I could
get some more data if we could get some
more data on what's going on with the
census I'd appreciate it m Mr ribson
used to have some really great census
charts and data and so I assume the the
new guy has continued to collect that
kind of data if I could get an update
sure the new gu is here that's soing Mr
roacha yeah Mr FL yes all right uh thank
you thank you Mr chair I do have a res I
do have Marissa was able it looks like
at this point we're 7 7% full for the uh
for the Direct Care positions at
Hamstead and that was a question I think
we were going to have a presentation of
that at the commission as well it's on
the
agenda may I add
something I don't
know go
ahead um I just in terms of State builds
I just wanted to remind folks we're
facing some of the similar stuff with
the friends at hospital in terms of when
did the design and then we had to come
back to you and ask for a little bit
more money so it's not too off of the
process that we have to do that but I
guess with that I just want to say we we
take it very seriously with how much
money we have and what are what is the
requirement that we have to do that so
we're we're not building more than what
we need to or than more than what we had
to and we're and we're taking that um
very
seriously it's an impressive sized
building for 18 people so there's
obviously going to be a lot of
classrooms and office space actually
there will be um minimal office space
we're trying to create more of an open
concept part of the reason for this
space being big is that when we have
Sight and Sound separations for youth um
we need to be able to have the ability
to swing and Flex for that so they would
be day you know space where they are
where they sleep where they eat where
they go to school and then where they
recreate um and when you have
restrictions and then when you have
gender issues uh separations as well so
so that's some of the reason for the
larger footprint on that thank you
further from the committee I'll move the
item I have a comment oh sorry all right
well I'll accept the motion from
representative Bradley second from
Senator
dallesandro and a question from
representative ER I I don't have a
question um but I am going to be voting
no um because I have the same concern
that Senator grey had um this there's
really no reason that this shouldn't
have gotten to us sooner I didn't get it
until today I I realized it was emailed
out yesterday but I didn't catch it um
and I don't know why there's you explain
why there's a rush but why wasn't there
Rush a month ago um if was that
important you don't need to
respond okay have a motion in a second
further discussion from committee
members seeing none are you ready for
the question all in favor of approving
the item say I I oppose no one me no one
in opposition you want to be recorded
please do so
motion is adopted thankk you
um we have an item in information that
we're all interested in about the
um Arguments for the uh payment
of of funds to the people that were
abused in the Youth Development Center
and its predecessors that person will
not be available here until
noon before I take a recess until that
time since all of you are here and
interested if there's anybody else that
has any question or anything they want
to add we'll have some time to to hear
from any of the public that wants to
question
anything all right that's the
opportunity um leg legislative budget
assistant Kane do you have anything no I
didn't know if you wanted to pick date
for the next meeting before you recess
that's good idea
sure tentatively that Friday would be
the 15th of
December uh some of us are going to have
a meeting earlier that
day
meeting capital budget overview rather
at 9: that same day and then I'd put
fist SCH at
people anybody have a a problem with the
10:00 there's no objection we'll set
that meeting for next month Friday
December 15th at 10 o'clock here in this
room for the fiscal committee meeting uh
most generally that that month of the
year is we're going to
accept things for the Consolidated
annual financial report because that's
have a deadline that same month and many
of you remember that we quite often are
giving an extension of the date but
hopefully
not we we've had a good we've had a good
comproller and and I'm I'm expecting
that we will be here to approve that so
that that will be the one of the major
items we know of right now so an
important thing to get that cfer moving
forward there's nothing else we'll be in
recess until
so what time is it
really qu 11 10:45 all right got plenty
of time for an early lunch and hopefully
back at noon those of you who are
interested in what's
process we are in
10:45
e
yeah